Speaker 1: All right.
So let's go to some CNN video.
CNN interviewed Trump lawyer Jim Trusty about
the leaked audio recording in which Trump
is at Bedminster Golf Club, not at Mar a Lago.
It's summer of 2021, long after.
Trump has left the White House and Biden is
president.
And Trump on the auto audio recording says,
I have a classified document here that I can't
show you.
Proving that Trump did not declassify all
of the documents that he took with him, meaning
he took classified documents to which he did
not have the right.
Then we go to CNN last night.
Here is Kaitlan Collins asking Trump's lawyer
if the documents were declassified, as Trump
told us they were.
Why is Trump on the recording saying, I can't
show you this because it's classified?
Very straightforward and simple question.
Jim Trusty unable to answer.
Speaker 2: That's correct.
Something you just said to Abby, which was
you referenced the fact that Trump was still
president when he left office.
You left Washington, I think about an hour
left in his presidency.
Are you saying that it was in that hour that
he declassified the documents that were taken
with him?
Now, your timing is a little bit off that
he he landed in Mar a Lago and was at his
residence while still president.
It was a little bit after that that Biden
was sworn in.
So he had the absolute authority to take every
one of those documents, any document he wants
with him.
When he left the White House, what happens
throughout history, through modern history.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Now he's already he's already being deceptive.
In some hypothetical sense.
If Trump goes through the declassification
process while president, he would then be
able to make the case that he can take documents.
He didn't do that.
Things are not de facto declassified because
Trump thought about it or because Trump took
them.
And Trump admits on the recording that these
are still classified documents, meaning he
did not declassify them.
This guy is lying and he's being deceptive.
Speaker 2: But if you take documents and archives
thinks they're entitled to it, they start
negotiating.
And that's what he did.
He was telling them things like, Hey, just
ask if you want anything more.
He gave them 15 boxes in January of 2022 after
some back and forth.
And just to be clear, you're making the argument
right now that by the time he was on the ground
in Florida after he left Washington, that
that is when he declassified all of these
documents that he took with him.
No, no, no.
I'm saying the documents he brought with him
are effectively declassify.
Speaker 1: Effectively is doing some heavy
lifting in this sentence.
And the problem is lawyers not working for
Trump say that that's not a thing and.
Speaker 2: Personalized under the Presidential
Records Act.
We're talking about constitutional authority
under the Constitution to declassify if he
wants to take stuff with him and say anything
I take with me is declassified.
If he wants to take it up and say anything
I read at night is declassified.
That was absolutely his right as president.
Speaker 1: Even if that were the case, he
didn't do it and admits the document is classified
in the summer of 2021.
Speaker 2: And the first of all, the Presidential
Records Act makes it clear that we don't even
care about classified information.
It is a statutory scheme.
But if this deals with presidential or personal
only if this was declassified, then why are
we told that he's on this tape basically telling
the people in the room that he can't share
it with them?
You are told by DOJ or FBI or whoever filtered
that to you, anything they can think of to
justify.
Speaker 1: All right.
So it's all unfair.
It's all a witch hunt to justify indicting
Trump.
Here's one more clip.
Here's Abby Phillip interviewing the same
guy, Jim Trusty.
And it doesn't really go any better.
Speaker 2: These tapes would indicate that
former President Trump knew that the documents
that he had.
Yes.
Classified?
Does that not make his statements about blanket
declassification and some statements by his
representatives?
Wouldn't that make those lies?
I'm not going to dignify the DOJ leak.
What I will tell you is that when you are.
Speaker 1: Because it's extremely inconvenient
to my client.
Speaker 2: That she's addressing, you don't
want to address the substance.
Well, it also be nice if you let me answer.
So let me just try to answer.
Speaker 1: Because he's not actually trying
to answer.
That's the.
Speaker 2: Thing.
I am trying to be responsive, but I'm not
going to bite on a leak campaign and try the
case in the media.
What I will tell you is there is no doubt
that as commander in chief and when the president
left Washington, D.C., for Mar a Lago, he
was actually still president when he left
for Mar a Lago with boxes of documents that
other people packed for him that he.
Speaker 1: Brought, At least now he's admitting
there were boxes.
Speaker 2: He was the commander in chief.
There is no doubt that he has the constitutional
authority as commander in chief to declassify
It does not have to go through some sort of
bureaucratic process to be declassified.
It will be very easy to simply prove that
he just declassified them because even though
he doesn't have to go through a process.
Right, he does have to decide that it's been
done.
Did he tell anyone?
Yes.
And can you prove it?
Sure.
But we're not doing it.
We're not going to try it.
He declassified this document that we're referring
to.
We're not going to try it.
Speaker 1: All right.
So as you can see, this is a very poor appearance
for Jim Trusty.
One lawyer wrote to me and said, you know,
these might be TV lawyer arguments, David,
to avoid answering the question and to obfuscate.
These are not arguments any sensible lawyer
would ever make in court.
So Trump's going to need something better
than Jim.
Trust these arguments if he hopes to to to
somehow explain this recording, if this actually
is something that leads to charges.
So, again, espionage being discussed as a
possible situation for Trump, we're going
to follow it super closely.